So, yeah, we've been asked a lot over the years.
所以，是的，这些年来我们经常被问到。
What was the work?
那个词是什么？
What did Ted say?
泰德说了什么？
It's created a lot of debate over the years.
这些年来这引发了大量的争论。
You know what?
你知道吗？
After all this time, 19 years later, to hell with it, I'm just going to say it.
时隔这么久，19年过去了，管他呢，我今天就要说出来。
I'm just going to officially say what the word was.
我要正式说出那个词到底是什么。
The word that Ted said was...
泰德说的那个词是……
the show really helped me get used to the sound of the language, learn new vocabulary, and practice grammar.
这部剧真的帮我习惯了这门语言的语音，学习新的词汇，并练习语法。
I remember I used to watch the same episodes several times, and it actually helped me pass my exams at university.
我记得我以前会把同一集看好几遍，这实际上确实帮我通过了大学考试。
And for me, it's a show that I discovered completely by accident.
对我来说，这是一部纯属偶然发现的剧。
I once borrowed a random DVD from the library, and it happened to me how I met you matter and it was the only DVD show that was available in English, so it started watching it and that's how I fell in love with it.
我曾经在图书馆随机借了一张DVD，正好是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，而且那是唯一一部有英语版本的DVD剧集，所以我开始看它，也就是这样我爱上了它。
I'm alone, oh, be soon in New York City.
我孤身一人，哦，很快就要去纽约了。
When I see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
当我看到你时，请允许我在纽约告诉你一切。
Hello, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
你好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈的浪漫史》幕后播客的又一期节目。
I'm your co-host, Josh Radner, and I'm here with my other co-host, Craig Thomas.
我是你的联合主持人乔什·拉德纳，和我在一起的是另一位联合主持人克雷格·托马斯。
Hey, Craig.
嘿，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Hey.
嘿。
We're talking about how I met your mother.
我们正在谈论《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
That's a show that I starred on from 2005 to 2014.
我在2005年到2014年期间主演了这部剧。
I played Ted Moseby on that show.
我在剧中饰演泰德·莫斯比。
Craig co-created the show with Carter Baze and we're sifting back through all of them.
克雷格和卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧，现在我们正在重新回看所有这些剧集。
We're in season two, which episode is this episode 11?
我们正处于第二季，这是第11集吗？
11 is not exactly half way, exactly half way.
11集不完全是正中间，不过也差不多正中间了。
We're halfway through the second season.
我们已经看完第二季的一半了。
Just a shout out to that wonderful voice note from our friend who learned English, from watching how I made my mother shout, just a whatever, a hello, a big hug, to all the people around the world that how I made my mother help them learn English.
向我们那位通过看《老爸老妈的浪漫史》来学习英语的朋友发来的精彩语音便签表示感谢，无论如何，向全世界所有因为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》而学会英语的人们问好、给个大大的拥抱。
It's one of the most delightful things I hear from people.
这是我从人们那里听到最令人高兴的事情之一。
It's one of the coolest things that we hear.
这是我们听到的最酷的事情之一。
If we could get in a time machine and go back, Josh, to 2005 us and be like, people are gonna learn English by watching this show.
如果我们能坐时间机器回到过去，乔什，回到2005年的我们，然后说，人们以后会通过看这部剧来学习英语。
It's just, it would have been something we weren't thinking in 2005.
这真的是我们在2005年时绝对想不到的。
Yeah, you're not planning that.
对，你根本不会这样去规划。
You're like, I wonder if this will help teach grammar.
你会想：不知道这能不能帮他们学语法？
Is the grammar good enough in this one?
这里的语法够不够好？
ESL teachers around the world will be using this.
全世界的ESL（英语为第二语言）老师都会用这个。
That's really why we're doing this.
这真的是我们现在在做这件事的原因。
What a public service.
真是功德无量啊。
Public service.
功德无量。
It is the best sort of weird side effect of this show's success.
这是这部剧成功带来的最好的一种奇妙副作用。
The Dearest really that is such an honor.
天哪，这真的是一种巨大的荣幸。
It's so cool.
太酷了。
and we hear it all the time, but I don't think, Alec, we've ever had a message directly of someone saying that.
我们经常听到这种说法，但我觉得，埃里克，我们以前从未收到过有人直接发来这样的消息。
So to have that on the record, on the pod is that, that was great.
所以能在播客中正式记录下来，真的很棒。
Thank you for that message.
谢谢你发来的这条消息。
Yeah, thank you.
是的，谢谢。
So today we're discussing how Lily stole Christmas, episode 11 of season two.
所以今天我们要讨论的是“莉莉偷走圣诞节”，第二季的第11集。
This was written, I believe, by Brenda Shea, is that right, Alec?
我想这一集是布伦达·谢伊写的，对吧，埃里克？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And when did this air on December 11th of 2006?
这一集是什么时候播出的？2006年12月11日吗？
Pause to contemplate our mortality.
暂停一下，思考一下我们的终有一死。
Condo player mortality and we're back.
顺便考虑一下终有一死，我们回来了。
Craig, tell us where this episode's spring from and also just give us a little summary of what this episode's about.
克雷格，告诉我们这一集的灵感是从哪里来的，顺便给我们简单总结一下这一集的内容。
And if you remember what the genesis for this episode was.
如果你还记得这一集的起源是什么的话。
Yeah, all of those things.
好的，所有这些。
Well, first of all, I think it's technically our first Christmas episode.
嗯，首先，我认为这严格来说是我们的第一集圣诞剧集。
I think this began from, we need to do a Christmas episode.
我想这源于我们觉得：我们需要拍一集圣诞节主题的剧。
We had a Halloween episode in season one, also written by Brenda Scheidt.
我们在第一季有一集万圣节主题的剧，也是布伦达·谢伊写的。
the slutty pumpkin, we had a Thanksgiving episode, we had a New Year's episode in the limo, we didn't really do a Christmas episode, I think we just didn't have an idea we were excited enough about.
即“荡妇南瓜”，我们还有一集感恩节主题的剧，在加长林肯里还有一集新年主题的剧，但我们一直没拍真正的圣诞节剧，我想我们只是当时没有产生足够让我们兴奋的点子。
I think we technically started the war on Christmas, that's where this political stuff came.
我想严格来说是我们挑起了对圣诞节的战争，政治正确的那一套就是从这里来的。
They're trying to erase Christmas.
他们正试图抹杀圣诞节。
Yeah, a lot of historians pegging on us.
对，很多历史学家都把这归咎于我们。
Yeah.
对。
Briefly contemplating my mortality again, and we're back again.
再次短暂地思考我的终有一死，然后我们又回来了。
No, but it's this episode came from that very universal place of what is the best friend's duty in a breakup is a best friend beholden to say bad things about the person that has dumped said other best friend and this idea we felt like we still had more to explore about Marshall and the police breakup, right?
不，不过这一集的灵感来源于一个非常普遍的问题：在分手时，好朋友的职责到底是什么？好朋友是否有义务说那些甩了另一位好朋友的人的坏话？我们觉得在这个想法上，我们还有更多关于马歇尔和莉莉分手的后续可以挖掘，对吧？
We were broken up for the first however many episodes, right, seven or eight episodes of this season, now this is episode 11.
在前好几集里他们都是处于分手状态的，对吧，这季的前七、八集都是这样，现在这是第11集。
And I remember we thought there's a little more to get out of this, this dramatic situation.
我记得当时我们在想，从这个戏剧性的情境中还能挖掘出更多东西。
There's a little more, how could something from that breakup in the summer come back around at Christmas time?
还有更多，夏天那场分手中的事情怎么会在圣诞节期间再次卷土重来呢？
And the plot of this episode is there's a recording where Ted says a very bad word about Lily.
这一集的剧情是，有一段录音，里面泰德说了关于莉莉的一个非常难听的词。
And that sets off a series of events that leads to Lily stealing Christmas.
这引发了一系列事件，最终导致莉莉偷走了圣诞节。
I'll allow the Grinch, hence how at least all Christmas.
我就勉为其难当个格林奇吧，因此这集叫《莉莉偷走圣诞节》。
Okay, so my memory is the breakup last until episode seven, but I had forgotten that the reverberations of this like go up until almost there, they walked on the aisle.
好吧，我的记忆是分手持续到了第七集，但我忘了这场分手的余波一直延续到他们几乎走进婚礼殿堂。
Like, it's a much longer kind of tremor or like aftershock than I had remembered, but I'm glad to see that because it does feel like, one thing I admire about you and Carter and the writers, like you were always, I think, pausing to go, what is the real thing happening?
就像是，这比我记忆中持续时间更长、波及范围更大的余震，但我很高兴看到这一点，因为这确实让人觉得——我非常佩服你、卡特还有编剧们的一点是——你们总是会停下来思考：真正发生的事情是什么？
Like what would be the real, the most real thing that we could then spin into comedy gold, but like let's, it just feels like you're really giving this like it's proper due and it's breath.
就像什么是真正的事情，最真实的事情，然后我们可以把它转化成喜剧的黄金素材，但这就好像你们真的给予了它应有的重视和呼吸空间。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, we really wanted to let things echo out.
是的，我们真的很想让事情产生回响。
We didn't like that sitcom convention where every week's a new week and the Etchus Sketch has been shaken up and it's just a tabular rasa.
我们不喜欢那种老套的情景喜剧惯例：每周都是新的一周，画板已经被擦得干干净净，一切都归零。
It's like, no, people hold on to things.
情况是，不，人们会把事情记在心里。
Shit comes back around.
破事儿总是会卷土重来的。
There's nothing is neat.
没有什么事情是干干净净的。
There's no, things aren't in need containers.
没有，事情都不是装在整洁的容器里的。
And that's what this episode comes from.
这就是这一集的灵感来源。
It's very funny how much old technology, namely an answering machine, the entire plot of this episode is hinged on an answering machine message.
很有趣的是，这么多的老旧技术——也就是答录机——这一集的整个剧情竟然全靠一条答录机留言支撑。
That can be played out loud and heard by Andy.
它可以被大声播放出来，并被安迪听到。
You can't recreate this episode today.
你今天无法再重现这样一集了。
Like this is not an episode.
就像这不是现在会有的剧情。
Why do they have that?
为什么他们会有那个？
That's still, I technically still have an answering machine.
我其实，严格来说我家里现在还留着一台答录机。
I have a landslide with an answering machine and people make fun of me.
我有一部带答录机的座机，人们还因此取笑我。
Do you know what's so funny when everyone went on to phones.
你知道最搞笑的是什么吗，当所有人都换了手机的时候。
I remember screenwriters saying, man, the answering machine, the public, you know, the answering machine where you press it and the voice goes into the room was such a useful platform, like a useful device for screenwriters.
我记得编剧们曾说过，天哪，答录机，公众都知道的，你可以按一下然后声音就会在房间里放出来的那个答录机，对编剧来说曾是一个多么好用的平台、多么好用的设备啊。
And it went away.
然后它就消失了。
Yeah.
对。
Remember Ted breaking up with, uh, uh, in season one?
还记得在第一季里泰德和……呃……分手的那个情节吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Uh, return to the shirt.
呃，把衬衫退回去。
He's breaking up with his, it's, forgive me, Natalie.
他在和他的——原谅我，娜塔莉。
I'm breaking out her.
我在和她分手。
Natalie.
娜塔莉。
Yeah.
对。
That's another big answering machine, uh, plot point.
那也是另一个重要的答录机……呃，剧情关键点。
I mean, just a little flashback with the idea of how much worse it was made by hearing heads voice bringing up that are on the answering machine and a whole surprise party of all their friends are hearing it.
我是说，只需一个小小的情节闪回，一想到听到老朋友的声音在答录机里说那些话，而且他们的一群朋友都在听，情况变得有多糟糕。
We have a few of those were really hinging ideas on answering machines.
我们有几个情节真的是把点子押在答录机上的。
It doesn't make us look super young at this point.
从现在来看，这显得我们可真不怎么年轻。
I was actually just weirdly discussing this with some friends this weekend.
其实这个周末我还真跟一些朋友怪异地讨论过这件事。
That kind of space between when your friend breaks up with to someone, how long do you wait to talk shit about them?
就是当你朋友和某人分手后，到那种程度，你要等多久才能说前任的坏话？
Is it your duty to immediately say they were whore?
你的责任是不是立刻说他们是个贱人？
You actually don't want to because there's a window when they still might get back together.
你其实又不想这么做，因为有一个窗口期，他们可能还会复合。
They might get back together.
他们可能会复合。
You can't talk too much shit about them, right?
你不能把对方贬得太惨，对吧？
Like you have to be like.
就像你必须得表现得……
That would have been a great observation to put in this episode, what you just said.
你刚才说的这个观察要是能放进这一集里，那就太棒了。
I have overcome with regret that we don't have that observation in the episode.
我感到十分懊悔，我们没能把这个观察放进这集里。
But what I loved, one of my favorite parts of this episode was that it was revealed, it was Ted's anger at Lily that was fueling it.
但我最喜欢的、这一集里我最喜欢的桥段之一，就是剧情揭晓，是泰德对莉莉的愤怒在推波助澜。
He wasn't just being a partisan on behalf of his friend.
他不只是在替朋友当坚定的拥护者。
He also felt like he got left.
他也觉得自己被抛下了。
You broke up with me.
你跟我绝交了。
You broke up with me as a friend.
你作为朋友跟我绝交了。
You didn't call me.
你甚至没给我打电话。
You know that one episode where he literally calls him his Ted, her best friend, you know?
你知道那一集吗，他字面意义上称呼他是泰德——她的最好朋友，你知道吗？
There's like a wounding and a rupture that Ted also felt and Ted was left with this baby, with this crying baby in the form of, you know, broken up Marshall.
泰德也感受到了某种创伤和决裂，而且泰德还留下来面对这个“婴儿”，面对痛苦分手的马歇尔这个哭泣的婴儿。
So.
所以。
I think that's what unlocks the episode.
我觉得这就是解开这一集密码的关键。
That piece late in the episode where Ted, for the first time in the episode, says what it's really about for him.
剧集后半部分的那个片段，泰德在这集中第一次说出了对他来说真正意味着什么。
You left me too, and I was also hurt and angry.
你抛下了我，我也是既受伤又愤怒。
And that's the moment it gets the way to understand what it was all about.
也就是那一刻，人们才开始理解这一切究竟是关于什么的。
I forgot that that is the key to the whole episode, that way in mind.
我差点忘了，那才是整个剧集的关键，我心里本来是这么想的。
Right, right, right.
对，对，对。
Yeah, you think it's one thing and it turns out it's actually deeper and more like layered and it's more about friendship than it is about like a break.
对，你以为是一回事，结果发现它其实更深层、更有层次感，它更多关乎友谊，而不是单纯的分手。
I mean, yeah.
我是说，对。
So the word that the kids hear is Grinch, right?
所以孩子们听到的那个词是“格林奇”，对吧？
It's almost like sandwiches for pot.
就像用三明治来代指大麻一样。
Like it's a sub-in word that is less offensive, less inflammatory, all that.
就像是一个替代词，没那么有攻击性，没那么煽动性，诸如此类。
When you've told me this, the word was, can we say that it started with a C?
当你们告诉我的时候，那个词是……我们可以说它是以C开头的吗？
Can we say that?
我们可以这么说吗？
I mean, it's the word that your friend will not forgive you for calling them, right?
我是说，那是你叫了之后，朋友绝不会原谅你的那个词，对吧？
Right, so we figured it had to be like a nuclear powered one rather than like a word that starts with a B or something, but we, you know, it's up to the imagination, right?
对，所以我们觉得它必须是一个核武器级别的词，而不是像以B开头的词之类的，但我们，你知道的，这就留给观众去想象了，对吧？
If people want to, if it's too far for people, they can imagine it one way or the other.
如果人们愿意，如果这对人们来说太过火了，他们可以按这样或那样的方式去想象。
But to be this nuclear, you figure it had to be worse than it be.
但为了达到这种核爆级别，你就会觉得它肯定比那个B开头的词还要糟糕。
But was this sub word always Grinch, like from draft one?
不过这个替代词一直都是“格林奇”吗，从初稿开始就是？
Yeah, I think so.
对，我想是的。
I think so.
我想是的。
But why do you want to do it?
但你为什么想这么做？
I remember it was so much clearer in the table draft that the word he called her was a C word.
我记得在剧本围读的初稿里，那个词非常清楚，他叫她的那个词是个C开头的词。
I think there was even a joke about the rhyme of the word.
我想当时甚至还有一个关于那个词压韵的笑话。
That got cut by the standards and practices.
那个笑话被审查部门给删掉了。
Do you remember this?
你还记得这个吗？
Yeah, I think that's the perfect time for our new segment.
对，我觉得这是我们推出新环节的绝佳时机。
Craig looks through his old email.
克雷格翻看他的旧电子邮件。
This is where I get the answer.
这就是我寻找答案的地方。
I'm gonna try to look up standards and press now.
我打算现在就去查查审查和出版部门的资料。
I'm not finding anything.
我什么也没找到。
Are you, yeah, okay, I'll work on this.
你在找吗，好吧，我来处理这个。
Hang on a second.
等一下。
But yeah, I think we had, I think you're right, Josh.
不过是的，我觉得我们有，乔希，我觉得你说得对。
I think we had something in there that pointed at, it had to have been the nuclear-powered word, and they were like, you can't do that.
我觉得我们在里边加了点暗示，暗示那肯定是个核武器级别的词，然后他们说：“你们不能这么做。”
And I can't remember, it would be such a better story If I can remember what it was.
我不记得了，如果我能记起那是什么的话，那会是个好得多的故事。
I think if you had to bet on what word it was, you'd have to go for the nuclear power gun.
我想如果你非得猜那是个什么词，你肯定得选那个核武器级别的词。
I think that's only right, that only makes sense.
我觉得这才是对的，这才说得通。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这段小调，要在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接听听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，但害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 找到它。
it's a fun exploration of what's what's a best friends role in in this situation and Ted's in a very tough place because they're both his best friend but he was he was the one scraping Marshall off the floor when Lily left I'm really pleased that by doing that we were able to reference one of my favorite films a Christmas story yeah the fudge the fudge of it all but I can say We got to have Bob Saget do Jean Shepherd saying, but I didn't say fudge.
这是一个有趣的探讨：在这种情况下去界定好朋友的角色是什么？泰德处在一个非常艰难的境地，因为他们俩都是他的好朋友，但当莉莉离开时，他是那个把马歇尔从地上扶起来的人。我非常高兴通过这种方式，我们能够致敬我最喜欢的电影之一《圣诞故事》。对，就是那个“操”的梗，虽然不能说出那个词，但我们可以让鲍勃·萨吉特模仿让·谢泼德说“但我没说那个词”。
Right.
对。
That was gold for us because that movie was so influential on how much a mother for Carter and I.
这简直是我们的宝藏，因为那部电影对卡特和我做《老爸老妈浪漫史》产生了极大的影响。
As we speak, I'm sitting right next to the leg lamp from a Christmas story.
此时此刻，我就坐在《圣诞故事》里那个灯罩是丝袜美腿的台灯旁边。
I could reach out, I'm currently touching the leg, the light up leg lamp from a Christmas story, which Carter gave me as a Christmas gift one year and was in our how much mother office, my writer's office and how much a mother for years and years.
我只要一伸手，我现在正摸着那条腿，那个来自《圣诞故事》的发光美腿台灯。那是卡特有一年送给我的圣诞礼物，它在我们的《老爸老妈浪漫史》办公室里，在我的编剧办公室里放了整整好几年。
I remember that.
我记得那个。
That movie's a huge influence playing with memory and like the narrator remembering and using the narrator as this tool to sort of embellish memory and play with that.
那部电影影响巨大，它玩转记忆，比如旁白在回忆，并且把旁白用作一种工具来美化记忆并做文章。
And it was so satisfying to get to do that.
能做到这一点真的让人感到非常满足。
And there's also a very overt love actually reference where they have to pretend to be Carol singers at the door.
里面还有一个非常明显的对《真爱至上》的致敬，他们必须假装在门口唱圣诞颂歌。
When it's when Ted's cousin's door at Staten Island, and they're singing, they decided to sing to cover what's happening.
那是当他们来到泰德在史泰登岛的表哥家门口，他们在唱歌，以此来掩盖正在发生的事情。
That's love actually.
那是《真爱至上》。
So we got to name Shaq.
所以我们终于可以致敬了。
We didn't get the Christmas this episode in year one, but by the time we got there, we're like, we're going to reference.
我们在第一年没能搞出圣诞特辑，但等我们做到了的时候，我们就想：我们要致敬这个。
He's doing what else is funny to me is like, they're like, okay, just start singing.
还有更有趣的是，他们当时就像是，好吧，直接开始唱吧。
And it's like just perfect for part of me.
唱得简直完美，甚至有点抢戏。
It's gorgeous.
太美妙了。
Bring it to your eye.
让你热泪盈眶。
Yeah, I think Neil and Jason went into a studio and recorded it really beautifully.
对，我想尼尔和杰森进录音室把它录得非常美妙。
And then we played it back.
然后我们把它放出来听。
And then we liked that subtle joke, which is also kind of a love actually joke.
然后我们很喜欢那个微妙的笑话，它其实也有点像《真爱至上》里的笑话。
And I remember that moment of love actually, where it turns out like the Prime Minister's security guy has this incredible singing voice.
我记得《真爱至上》里的那个时刻：结果发现首相的安保人员有一副令人惊叹的好嗓子。
And Hugh Grant plays this moment where he looks at him like, holy shit, how are you going to sing?
休·格兰特当时的表情就是，天呐，你怎么能唱得这么好？
Or is King One's List or whatever?
还是说像《辛德勒的名单》之类的？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, so we had to wait for the Christmas episode, but we got to have a lot of fun with it.
对，所以我们不得不等到圣诞特辑，但我们在其中玩得很开心。
And it is, yeah, it's a real, again, I don't think we did it in year one because we just didn't have a great idea.
而且，是的，这确实是……再说一次，我觉得我们在第一年没拍成，是因为我们当时没有一个绝妙的点子。
This is a juicy idea, right?
这是一个很有嚼劲的点子，对吧？
What Lily missed that whole summer, and she missed what her, essentially her best friend was saying about her to Marshall.
莉莉错过了整个夏天，而她错过了她的挚友本质上对马歇尔说的话。
And I love, it was important was because we figured people would interpret this as the nuclear powered worst version of what Ted could have said.
而且我喜欢，这之所以重要，是因为我们觉得人们会把这解读为泰德可能说过的核武器级别的最糟糕版本。
You're right, it only makes sense.
你说得对，这绝对说得通。
Everyone's reaction in hearing the word in the bar, little kids, it only makes sense.
大家在酒吧听到这个词时的反应，小孩子们，这完全说得通。
We felt we had to justify it and earn it.
我们觉得自己必须证明这一点，并赢得它。
So going back to the summer and seeing, reminding the audience how miserable Marshall was and how much Ted had to parent him through that.
所以回到夏天，看看并提醒观众马歇尔有多惨，以及泰德花了多少精力去照顾他。
And that Ted actually, it was actually healthy for Ted to milk a little bit of anger out of Marshall at that moment and say, say one bad thing about her.
而且泰德当时，让马歇尔稍微发泄一点怒火对泰德来说其实是健康的，并说，说她一句坏话。
If you glorify her, you'll be stuck in this forever.
如果你把她美化，你就会永远困在这个死胡同里。
And that was the issue.
问题就在这里。
She left you in one San Francisco.
她把你一个人扔在旧金山。
What do you call that?
你管这叫什么？
I love you, he says fiercely independent.
我爱你，他说得非常独立。
Say one bad thing about her.
说她一句坏话。
There's only one of her.
她可是独一无二的。
Right.
没错。
You know, he just, he was so stuck.
你知道，他当时就是深陷其中。
And you actually, I would argue, you have to go through that, right?
而且我可以说，你实际上必须经历这个过程，对吧？
You have to go through that time where you get to be angry.
你必须经历那种可以生气的时期。
Yeah.
是的。
He needed to do that.
他需要这样做。
And Ted was a good friend to him, I think by doing what he did.
我认为泰德通过他的所作所为，是一个好朋友。
And he was a bad friend to Lily at that moment by doing that.
但他在那个时刻因为那样做，对莉莉来说是个坏朋友。
And I love the conundrum of that.
我很喜欢这种两难的境地。
How do you do everything to everyone?
你怎么能对所有人都面面俱到呢？
It's impossible.
这不可能。
But also I think he, one thing that I think that you guys do really well here is a breakup is not just between two people, especially if the social fabric is just so woven.
但我也觉得，我觉得你们这里做得很好的其中一点是，分手不仅仅是两个人的事，特别是当社交网络如此紧密交织的时候。
The three of them were like, they're salt, pepper, and cumin.
他们三个人就像，他们是盐、胡椒和小茴香。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
they're, they're a gang, right?
他们，他们是一个小团体，对吧？
One of my rejects, yeah.
我的废话之一，是的。
And I think that, that Lily's leaving, yes, obviously it annihilates Marshall, but it also like holds the rug out from under their, all their lives.
而且我认为，莉莉的离开，是的，显然击垮了马歇尔，但它也抽走了他们所有人生活的地基。
It's not just that he has to take care of Marshall.
不仅仅是他必须照顾马歇尔。
It's that the, she changed the whole dynamic of their, they're in a totally different ecosystem after that.
而是她改变了他们整个动态，在那之后他们处在一个完全不同的生态系统中。
And she.
而且她。
They were like kids in a divorce, Ted was like a kid in a divorce and it's that's right.
他们就像经历父母离异的孩子，泰德就像经历父母离异的孩子，就是这样。
Oops, I sided with Dad a little more than Mom because Mom went away.
糟糕，我稍微偏向了爸爸多一点，因为妈妈走了。
Sorry.
对不起。
But it's also, there's something healthy about him getting to say to Mom, this really hurt me, you know?
但这也有一种健康的地方，就是他能够对妈妈说，这真的伤害了我，你知道吗？
This really hurt.
这真的很伤人。
Yeah, and it hurt me because it hurt our relationship.
是的，它伤害了我，因为它伤害了我们的关系。
I actually thought my memory was in that speech near the end when Ted actually gets to say that to Lily in her tiny apartment there with all the decorations, which is amazing.
我其实以为我的记忆里，在快结尾的那场戏里，泰德在莉莉那个摆满装饰品的小公寓里对莉莉说出那番话时，那太棒了。
I thought Ted said more about, and I was really left picking Marshall up.
我以为泰德说得更多，关于“我真的留下来收拾马歇尔”。
I was trying to put a broken man, I was putting Humpty Dumpty back together again all summer, and you were not there.
整个夏天我都在试图把一个破碎的男人，把蛋头先生重新拼凑起来，而你不在。
But he actually doesn't say much of that.
但他其实没说那么多。
He really prioritizes, you hurt my feelings, which I felt was the more surprising and interesting take, and I had forgotten how much that's the point of that scene.
他真正优先表达的是，你伤害了我的感情，我觉得这是一个更让人意外且有趣的切入点，而且我忘了那场戏的核心其实是这个。
And I think we covered that friendship.
我觉得我们展现了那种友谊。
I think we covered that he had to, you know what I'm saying?
我觉得我们展现了他必须，你知道我在说什么吗？
It was like another beat that was like true.
这就好像是另一个很真实的节拍。
Yeah.
是的。
That hadn't been covered, yeah.
那是之前没涵盖到的，是的。
And gave Justice to Ted the depth of Ted's friendship with Lilly, it's not just Marshall's girlfriend came back around, it's my best friend.
这也体现了泰德对莉莉友谊的深度，不只是马歇尔的女朋友回来了，这是我最好的朋友。
Yeah, my college.
对，我的大学。
Hosted me for three months, yeah, and now she's back.
收留了我三个月，对，现在她回来了。
And the idea that, I like the idea on this, and it's actually sort of similar to Atlantic City, that idea of, you have to fully face things, right?
而且这个想法，我很喜欢这个想法，这其实有点像《大西洋城》，那种必须彻底面对现实的想法，对吧？
Atlantic City, they're like, we're gonna run away and get married real quick.
在《大西洋城》里，他们就像是，我们要马上私奔结婚。
We're gonna elope to avoid the family frowning at Lilly, the Minnesota family frowning at Lilly for having run off.
我们要私奔，以免明尼苏达州的家族对莉莉私奔感到不悦。
And then they realize we have to face it.
然后他们意识到，我们必须面对它。
This is like the one of the last pieces of the puzzle to put back together, Ted and Lily never faced off about the worst fucking summer that Ted just had other than being in love with Robin, he had a horrible summer with his best friend in a coma, basically.
这就像是拼图的最后几块之一，泰德和莉莉从来没有正面冲突过，去面对泰德刚刚经历的那个该死的糟糕夏天，除了爱上罗宾，他在挚友几乎陷入昏迷的情况下度过了一个糟糕的夏天。
Well, it also speaks to that thing we're saying, like the kind of strange paradox of how many people find comfort in this show while watching the characters go through deep discomfort.
嗯，这也呼应了我们刚才说的那个现象，就是那种奇特的悖论：许多人在观看角色经历极度不适的同时，却在这部剧中找到了慰藉。
Absolutely, that's very uncomfortable.
没错，这确实让人很不舒服。
that's the paradox of the show.
这就是这部剧的悖论。
It's people's comfort show, and it mostly depicts suffering.
这是人们的慰藉之剧，但它主要描绘的是痛苦。
I wanna say, Josh, something lovely I thought about your acting in this.
我想说，乔什，我觉得你在这部剧里的表演有一点非常美妙。
And you had mentioned episodes and episodes, maybe a whole season ago that you had spoken with Al Pacino on the set of your show about, and I think he was one that said to you, the camera loves to see people thinking, right?
你曾提到过，在好几集甚至可能是一整季前，你在片场和阿尔·帕西诺聊过，我想正是他对你说过，镜头喜欢看人们思考，对吧？
That was what you had.
这就是你的心得。
On hunters, yeah.
在《猎人》剧组里，是的。
So, right, so right before you blow up, that Lilly, right before you sort of tell the truth.
所以，就在你爆发之前，对莉莉，就在你准备说出真相之前。
No, you hurt me.
不，你伤害了我。
I did not remember this episode at all and I was not ahead of the story at all.
我完全不记得这一集了，而且我也完全猜不到剧情的发展。
I did not know where it was going.
我不知道它会走向何方。
But right before it, we see you.
但在那之前，我们看到了你。
We're watching you.
我们在看着你。
And I just had, I was like, oh my God, Ted's something's happening in Ted right now.
我当时就觉得，哦天哪，泰德，泰德现在心里有什么事情正在发生。
He's holding something back and it's about to come out.
他有所保留，而这就要爆发了。
And I could not predict it.
我无法预测。
I did not know what it was.
我不知道那是什么。
But it was a love like, ooh, what's Ted got going on?
但那种感觉就像是，哇，泰德心里在盘算着什么？
And Josh, I just thought that was lovely.
乔什，我只是觉得那演得太棒了。
Oh, that's so nice.
哦，太好了。
Feel free to compliment me anytime, Alec, on the show.
亚历克，随时欢迎你在节目中夸我。
But I, it's so funny, Jordana, when we were watching it this morning, she was also like really startled by that moment.
但我觉得，乔丹娜，今天早上我们看的时候太好笑了，她对那个时刻也感到非常震惊。
And pretty delighted, I think just like the psychology of it, she really appreciated like, oh, there's something about the reveal that it wasn't just, he wasn't just being a partisan on behalf, wasn't just defending his friend.
而且相当高兴，我想单从心理学角度来看，她真的很感激，哦，那个揭晓过程有些特别之处，不只是，他不仅仅是作为同党在辩护，不仅仅是在捍卫他的朋友。
He was angry, he was angry at her, he felt betrayed, he felt left, you know?
他是生气的，他生她的气，他感到被背叛，他觉得自己被抛下了，你知道吗？
I think there's something about that chosen family where you want it to stick together, especially if you come from a certain amount of brokenness, which Lily does and Ted does, both of them.
我觉得在那种选定的家庭里，你会希望大家团结一致，尤其是如果你经历过一定程度的破碎，莉莉和泰德都是这样，他们两个都是。
They're trying to ask you.
他们正试图问你。
Let me ask you this question right on this scene here from G.
让我直接就吉·万纳发来的这场戏问你这个问题。
Vanner, who by the way sends in lots of great questions, who says, Josh, the fight between Ted and Lily and her apartment is one of the most raw and honest confrontations between friends in the show's early seasons.
顺便说一句，他发来了很多精彩的问题，他说，乔希，泰德和莉莉在她公寓里的争吵是该剧早期几季中朋友之间最真实、最赤裸的对峙之一。
How did you and Allison prepare for that scene?
你和艾莉森是如何为那场戏做准备的？
Was it a challenge to tap into that level of anger and hurt within what is usually a very warm and supportive friendship?
在通常非常温馨和支持的友谊中，要调动出那种愤怒和受伤的程度，是一个挑战吗？
I mean, it's just a script, it's just acting, but tell us about that.
我的意思是，这只是剧本，这只是表演，但给我们讲讲那个吧。
I don't think, you know, Allie and I would never talk about, everyone had their own process.
我不觉得，你知道的，艾莉和我从不会讨论，每个人都有自己的流程。
But I sometimes think that the stuff that looks hard to do emotionally is what actors delight in doing.
但我有时觉得，那些在情感上看起来很难做的事情，正是演员们乐于去做的。
It's like, to have a raw confrontation with Alison Hannigan in the middle of an episode, like, yeah, hand me, throw me the ball, put me in, you know?
就像，在剧集中间和艾莉森·汉妮根来一场赤裸裸的对峙，就像，是的，把球传给我，把我换上场，你知道吗？
Like, it's delightful.
就像，这太令人高兴了。
And Ali was always never, like, never not surprising and truthful.
而且艾莉总是从不，就是从不缺乏惊喜和真实感。
And so it was very, it was very easy.
所以这非常，非常容易。
It was like, some of my favorite TED scenes are with Lily, weirdly, as we're watching this back.
就像，重温这些的时候，我最喜欢的一些泰德的戏份居然是和莉莉在一起的，这挺奇怪的。
There's some, even, we'll get to it, but like the shot of them being stoned together, like, but, but they had a lot of, I think when, when both of them need either real truth talking to or, or, or can't say something to anyone else but each other, those are some of the best scenes.
有些，甚至，我们待会儿会讲到，比如他们一起抽大麻的镜头，但是，但是他们有很多，我觉得当他们两个需要有人说真话，或者除了彼此无法向任何人倾诉时，那些就是最棒的戏份。
It's not like you wake up in the morning and go, Oh, I got that hard scene with Ali today.
并不是说你早上醒来会想，哦，我今天有和艾莉的那场重头戏。
You're just like skipping to work.
你只会像蹦蹦跳跳去上班一样。
You're just like, happy, you know, you know, it's juicy.
你只会觉得，很高兴，你知道，你知道，这很有嚼劲。
I always loved the more serious stuff because I felt like that was one of the things I was hired for.
我一直很喜欢更严肃的内容，因为我觉得那是聘用我的原因之一。
Yeah.
是的。
Was like, for the earnest part.
可以说，主要是为了那份真诚。
And I was like, Okay, this is why I'm hired, this is good, this is fun.
当时我想，好吧，这就是我被雇用的原因，这很好，这很有趣。
I'd never found it to be like a high level of difficulty.
我从来不觉得这有什么多高的难度。
It was more like, this is what I'm here for, you know?
更像是，这就是我来这里的目的，你知道吗？
Ted and Lily on the show are often the moral compass, one or the other of them in an episode is often the moral compass or the kind of emotional grown-up through line in a lot of ways.
在剧中，泰德和莉莉通常是道德风向标，每集里总有一个人担任道德风向标，或者在很多方面充当情感上的成年人主线。
And then when the two of them would turn on each other, would have to fight and be at odds.
然后，当他们俩反目成仇、不得不争吵并产生分歧时。
It was, I leaned forward in those scenes as a viewer.
作为一个观众，我在看那些场景时忍不住向前倾了倾身子。
I'm like, this is really interesting.
我想，这真的很有趣。
The two people who are supposed to be steering the ship are fighting, so who's steering the ship?
两个本该掌舵的人在吵架，那到底是谁在掌舵？
Right, it rocks the whole, the whole family gets rocked, you know?
没错，整个局面都被震撼了，整个家庭都被震撼了，你知道吗？
They are kind of the mom and dad in certain ways, not Marshall and Lily.
在某些方面，他们有点像爸爸妈妈，不是马修和莉莉。
It's actually Ted and Lily are the mom and dad.
实际上泰德和莉莉才是爸爸妈妈。
It really is.
真的就是这样。
And that's why this fight takes, if I ever regret of, you know, every now and again, I'll hit upon I wish we'd had even more scenes between just Ted and Lily, because you guys were great together.
这就是为什么这场争吵……如果说我有什么遗憾的话，每隔一段时间，我就会想，真希望我们能有更多只属于泰德和莉莉的对手戏，因为你们俩在一起太棒了。
Although you could say it impacts because we didn't do it all the time.
尽管你可以说正是因为我们不常这么做，才让它更有冲击力。
And then when it would happen and that tension would happen, it was really surprising and interesting.
而当这种情况发生、这种紧张感出现时，真的让人感到惊喜和有趣。
And maybe that's part of what made it work.
也许这就是它奏效的部分原因吧。
I know.
我懂。
Yeah.
是啊。
But I love you guys when you guys are in a real emotional content conversation.
但我真的很喜欢你们俩进行真正的情感内容对话的时候。
There's a moment when the dam breaks and friends are allowed to shit talk.
有一个时刻，情绪的堤坝崩溃了，朋友们终于可以开始说坏话了。
Yes.
没错。
The X.
X。
X。X。
Yes.
是的。
And the scene in the bar of the three guys shit talking Lily is hilarious to me.
三个男人在酒吧里说莉莉坏话的那场戏，对我和来说太搞笑了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Because they're digging so deep to come up with bad shit.
因为他们挖空心思想要找出恶毒的事情来说。
She's a really good person, but I love Neil.
她明明是个非常好的人，但我爱尼尔。
I'm an artist.
我可是个艺术家。
She doesn't even wear a beret.
她甚至都不戴贝雷帽。
That's a misconception.
那是个误解。
Like Barney's idea of an artist is so funny.
巴尼对艺术家的看法简直太搞笑了。
It's funny.
太搞笑了。
I love just watching the damn break and then there's something that is also very pleasing.
我就是喜欢看情绪崩溃，而且其中也有某种非常过瘾的地方。
There's just these little moves that the show makes.
剧中就是有这样一些微小的小动作。
I love when Ted Marshall and Barney are all on the same page.
我喜欢泰德、马修和巴尼意见完全一致的时候。
There's something very pleasing about the street.
那种纯粹男人们在一起的感觉非常过瘾。
They're just being dudes.
他们只是在做纯粹的男人。
just be a dude.
只是做个纯爷们。
Yeah, that was a good moment.
对，那是个好时刻。
And you like just to pause for a second, like I think everybody's been either on one side or both sides of that equation at different times in their life.
而且就像你想暂停一下一样，我觉得每个人在人生的不同阶段，都经历过那种情况的一方，或者双方都经历过。
So I think that's why this episode works.
所以我觉得这就是为什么这一集这么管用。
I people love this episode, but I do, I have seen debates from fans of like, should Ted not have said that.
人们都很喜欢这一集，但我确实也看到过粉丝们的争论，比如泰德当时是不是不该说那些。
You don't say that, Lily's also Ted's friend.
你不该说那些，莉莉也是泰德的朋友啊。
I feel like there was some debate.
我觉得当时确实有一些争论。
Was it right or wrong for Ted to say that?
泰德说那些话究竟是对还是错？
I would argue it's just human.
我会认为这很有人情味。
It's just human nature, right?
这只是人性，对吧？
Like there's no.
就像没有……
I don't lose any respect or affection for Ted, that he did that.
我不会因为他做了那件事而对泰德失去任何尊重或喜爱。
Right.
没错。
Like I just don't, you know, but maybe.
我就是不会，你知道的，但也许吧。
Yeah.
是啊。
I think he makes his case pretty well, that's why he's doing it, you know what I mean?
我觉得他把自己的理由解释得很清楚，这也是他当时那么做的原因，你知道我的意思吗？
And some ways comes around.
某种程度上她也想通了。
Like she in a way comes around and I just got a text from my wife who's listening in.
就像她最后以某种方式释怀了，我刚收到我正在收听节目的妻子发来的短信。
She says, this is hard, not just for friends, but this is hard as a therapist too.
她说，这很难，不仅是对朋友而言，作为一名治疗师这也是个难题。
Like at what point do you, if there's a breakup?
比如在什么情况下，如果发生了分手？
Yes.
是的。
like, how do you play that as a therapist?
作为一个治疗师，你该如何处理这种情况？
Also interesting question.
这也是个有趣的问题。
We'll have to have her.
我们以后得让她也来聊聊。
I'm sure at some point, you just you just bust out the seaward again.
我敢肯定在某个时刻，你就会忍不住再次爆粗口。
Right?
对吧？
I've heard her.
我听到了。
I heard her.
That door is only soundproof so much.
那扇门的隔音效果也就那样吧。
I've heard her say that constantly.
我经常听到她说那个词。
But you have to wait till the right moment.
但你得等到合适的时机。
Yes.
是的。
They cover that in grad school.
他们在研究生院里学过这个。
Oh my god, it's a dilemma.
天哪，这是一个两难境地。
It's a very it's a real dilemma.
这真的是一个非常真实的困境。
I think Ted was being such a good friend to Marshall and yeah, you know, there was shit to work out.
我觉得泰德当时是在做马修的好朋友，而且是的，你知道，有些烂摊子需要解决。
There was shit left to work out that they worked out before they could have a lovely Christmas together.
还有一些历史遗留问题需要在他们一起过一个美好的圣诞节之前解决掉。
That's what this is.
事情就是这样。
And it's just real.
而且这很真实。
I do think just shout out to Neil, like the sea story of Barney not admitting he's sick.
我必须向尼尔致敬，比如巴尼生病却不承认的这条副线。
Like he's so funny.
他太搞笑了。
That's just a simple little thing that he elevated that could have sucked.
这只是一个本来可能会很烂的简单小桥段，却被他升华了。
It's just basically the littlest thing we could have handed him, and he elevated it and joined the real master class.
这基本上就是我们能交给他的最小的活儿，但他却将其升华，展现了真正的教科书级演技。
But also, it speaks to his disgust with mortality and humanity, like he can't admit vulnerability or fallibility on any level.
但同时，这也反映了他对衰老和人性的抗拒，他无法在任何层面上承认自己的脆弱或会犯错。
So again, it's kind of like the getting Ted to wear a suit kind of thing in the first.
所以这又有点像第一季里劝泰德穿西装那种感觉。
There's always something subterranean going on with Barney that's beyond just the surface comedy.
巴尼的内心深处总有一些潜台词，超越了表面的喜剧效果。
He really genuinely is like, I'm fine, like he can't not be awesome.
他真心实意地觉得自己“我很好”，他无法接受自己不“酷”的状态。
So he has to deny that this is happening to his body.
所以他必须否认这种状况正在他的身体里发生。
Yeah.
是啊。
And Robin has to become a caretaker, which isn't the most natural speed for Robin.
而罗宾不得不承担起照顾者的角色，这并不是罗宾最自然的行事风格。
You got to see sort of these new vulnerable speeds and these two characters who are very strong.
你得以看到这两个本很坚强的角色展现出那种新的脆弱一面。
Yeah.
是啊。
You know, it occurred to me, I actually thought if you were really mapping out Robin and Barney, her serving him soup and tending him while he's sick might be the first moment where Barney starts to feel like, Oh, I like, I feel safe with this woman or I feel like I can be myself with this woman in a way that's different, you know, he would never let any of these other women see him in the state.
你知道，我突然想到，我甚至觉得如果你真的在梳理罗宾和巴尼的关系，她在他生病时为他端汤、照顾他的那一刻，可能是巴尼开始觉得：“哦，我喜欢，我觉得在这个女人身边很安全”或者“我觉得在这个女人面前我可以做自己”的第一个瞬间，这种感觉很不一样，你知道，他绝不会让其他任何女人看到他这种状态。
I also love seeing him wear Ted's clothes.
我也很喜欢看他穿着泰德的衣服。
I think they just literally put him in my.
我觉得他们简直就是直接让他穿了我的……
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Definitely.
肯定的。
I think it's tough.
我觉得这挺微妙的。
Ted has worn on the show before and he's in Ted's bed.
泰德以前在剧里穿过这身衣服，而且他还躺在泰德的床上。
It's so intimate.
这太亲密了。
He's just in Ted's bed.
他就在泰德的床上。
This snotty mess like was Ted consulted about before Barney got in that bed with leaking flu what in his body.
巴ney钻进那张流感病毒肆虐的床之前，有没有征求过泰德的同意，搞得一团鼻涕。
He hates like sartorially.
他从穿衣风格上就很嫌弃。
He hates what he's wearing, but he also has to admit it's very comfortable.
他讨厌自己身上穿的衣服，但又不得不承认这衣服真的很舒服。
Yeah, it's comfortable.
对，很舒服。
And he's such a baby.
而且他就像个小婴儿。
I hate you.
我讨厌你。
He just snaps at Robin.
他对罗宾没好气地发脾气。
He's just, he devolves into babyhood.
他简直，他退化成了婴儿状态。
It's funny.
这太搞笑了。
It's fit the story well.
这很符合这个故事。
I don't remember if we were clever enough to have thought this, but Barney not admitting he's sick, but the sickness winning in the end is kind of like the whole episode in a way.
我不记得我们当时是不是足够聪明想到了这一点，但巴尼死不承认自己生病，而病情最后却占了上风，从某种程度上来说就像是整集剧情的缩影。
There's something lingering.
总有些挥之不去的东西。
There's a sickness in Ted and Lily's dynamic and Marshall's dynamic.
泰德和莉莉的相处模式中，以及马修的相处模式中，都有一种病态。
There's some part of this breakup that didn't get fully fleshed out with the toxins of it and it catches back up with them just like sickness catches up with Barney.
这场分手的某些部分并没有完全暴露出它的毒性，而它最终还是追上了他们，就像疾病追上巴尼一样。
There's something that kind of links up there.
这两者之间某种程度上是有联系的。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
There's a nice moment of additional moment of old tech when it's clearly new on Ted's phone that he can say the name and call the person.
当泰德在手机上能说出名字并呼叫对方时，这明显是一项新技术，这给剧集增添了一个有趣的怀旧时刻。
Right.
没错。
And it doesn't really hold up because no one does that anymore.
而且现在看来这已经站不住脚了，因为现在没人会那么做了。
It was new technology at the moment that seems very data now.
这在当时是新技术，现在看起来很有年代感。
I feel like, do you guys do that?
我觉得，你们会那样做吗？
Do you do call Baba?
你们会用语音拨号找爸爸吗？
No, I never do that.
不，我从来不那样做。
I never do that.
我从来不那样。
Maybe I guess some people do.
不过我想也许有些人会吧。
But I feel like Ted would be like kind of an early adopter.
但我觉得泰德会是那种尝鲜者。
Like he'd try to do it.
就像他会尝试去用一样。
But also it's a it's character revealing because Ted is ultimately like a good guy and his friends in distress.
但这也展现了角色性格，因为泰德骨是个好人，而且他的朋友正处于困境中。
Obviously person he did like a third tier friend clearly.
显然他去见的这个人顶多算是个三流朋友。
Like somebody doesn't talk to you all that much and he suddenly has dinner plans and he's just like, oh God, what a nightmare.
就像那种平时不怎么联系，突然约你吃晚饭，然后他就会想，哦天哪，这简直是场噩梦。
20 minutes.
20分钟。
20 minutes later.
20分钟后。
With Billy right before Christmas.
跟比利在一起，就在圣诞节前夕。
I liked Christ Moss, more Christ to our Spanish friends.
我喜欢“基督之苔”（Christ Moss），对我们的西班牙朋友来说就是更多的基督。
That was a great line.
那真是句绝妙的台词。
And what is this the debut?
这算是首次登场吗？
I love how Lily tells Ted's mom.
我喜欢莉莉向泰德妈妈告状的方式。
She tells on Ted that he used that word.
她告发了泰德用了那个词。
That little scene and that's where we meet Clint who becomes a more like Ted's mom's new boyfriend, Clint who we heard about.
那个小片段就是我们第一次见到克林特的地方，他后来成了泰德妈妈的新男友，也就是我们听说过的那个克林特。
That's the debut of Clint, right?
那是克林特的首次登场，对吧？
That's a debut of Clint.
那是克林特的首次登场。
And yeah, all I'll say is he's a little bit based on some people that I've encountered in life.
对，我只想说他多多少少是以我在生活中遇到过的一些人为原型的。
Not still in the picture, but definitely Clint brings things up for me.
虽然现在不联系了，但克林特确实勾起我一些回忆。
And is this debut of Ted's middle name is Evelyn?
这是泰德的中间名叫伊芙琳（Evelyn）的首次曝光吗？
Is this the- No, I think it was hinted at before.
这是——不，我觉得之前暗示过。
I think it's been hinted at before in the season and a half.
我觉得在这季半里之前就暗示过了。
I had boy this by- Well, I think it's great how Barney calls him Ted Vivian.
我当时——好吧，我觉得巴尼叫他泰德·维维安（Ted Vivian）太搞笑了。
He has it a little bit wrong.
他稍微叫错了。
But it's also like, those are like, you could swap those names out.
但这也像是，那些名字，你可以把它们调换一下。
Like it's.
就像是。
Yeah, totally.
对，完全可以。
Yeah.
对。
And Ted, it's also funny.
而且泰德，这也很好笑。
Like Ted has these super religious relatives in Staten Island who you never hear from again.
泰德在史泰登岛有一些超级虔诚的亲戚，你之后再也听不到他们的消息了。
Yeah.
对。
What about the cousin was a moon zappa?
那个表亲是月亮·扎帕（Moon Zappa）吗？
Right.
没错。
I forgot about that entirely until the credits came up.
直到演职员表出来我都完全把这事忘光了。
Yeah.
对。
Did you talk to her?
你跟她聊过吗？
Did you get to know her at all?
你有稍微了解她一点吗？
Oh, yeah, we were, I don't know if you remember, but I like friends.
哦，对，我们曾——我不知道你记不记得，但我像个粉丝一样。
That was so much.
那真是太棒了。
I'm surprised that in dork out in term.
我很惊讶自己当时居然那么疯狂。
But maybe I had the still photographer take a picture of me wearing the red sweater with her and all the kids.
不过也许我让剧照摄影师拍了一张我和她以及所有孩子一起穿着红毛衣的照片。
Yes.
是的。
And for a holiday card that year, I said, happy holidays love the radiners.
当年为了节日贺卡，我说，节日快乐，拉迪纳一家（The Radiners）留。
And it was me with like, not my wife and not my children.
照片上是我和——既不是我的妻子，也不是我的孩子。
But it was like, I still, when I was cleaning out my house in LA this summer, I found a bunch of those cards that I still have.
但就像是，我至今——今年夏天我在洛杉矶清理房子时，还翻出了一堆我留着的那些贺卡。
That's so funny.
太搞笑了。
That was hilarious.
那真是太荒谬了。
Yeah.
对。
You just stepped right into that photo shoot where the husband was and it was, yeah.
你直接走进了那个丈夫所在的合影里，然后就——
Yeah.
对。
And it was, yeah, that was hilarious.
然后就，那太搞笑了。
She was really funny.
她真的很有趣。
Moon zappa.
月亮·扎帕。
So cool.
太酷了。
I know.
我知道。
That's a cool that a casting.
这选角太酷了。
But also funny that like Ted goes to dinner and they're like, well, put on this red sweater.
但也很搞笑，泰德去吃晚饭，他们就说，穿上这件红毛衣吧。
Like you have to wear the red sweater.
就像你非得穿那件红毛衣不可。
The red sweater.
那件红毛衣。
Yeah.
对。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
is Ted Jewish, is Ted half Jewish?
泰德是犹太人吗？泰德有犹太血统吗？
It was revealed he was half Jewish later, much later.
后来才透露他是犹太混血，是很久以后了。
Later, right, which is what feels right, but we so wanted to do all these bits about Christmas that we just committed really early on in the series.
后来，对吧，这样才说得通，但我们太想做那些关于圣诞节的桥段了，所以我们在剧集一开播就早早地设定好了。
Like, well, we'll just say he's at least partially, that's like, you know, at least half of his family celebrated.
比如，好吧，我们就说他至少有一部分是，这就好比，你知道的，至少他家里有一半人过这个节。
Well, that's like you taking, I do crossword puzzles and you're like, now Ted does crossword puzzles.
这就好比你拿走了——我玩填字游戏，然后你就说“泰德也玩填字游戏”。
It's like, I'm Jewish, you're like, Ted's half Jewish.
这就好像，我是犹太人，你就说“泰德有一半犹太血统”。
It's just like, it's like tailoring the suit.
这感觉就像是在量身定制西装。
We talked around the actor.
我们是围绕着演员来设定的。
Yeah.
对。
The Backdoor Santa song is really good.
《后门圣诞老人》（Backdoor Santa）这首歌真的很棒。
That's used.
就是用到的那首。
Yeah, that song was later sampled to become Christmas time in Hollis, Queens by run DMC.
对，那首歌后来被Run DMC采样，改编成了《Christmas time in Hollis, Queens》。
But it is a fantastic, it's by Clarence Carter.
但这首歌真的很棒，是克拉伦斯·卡特唱的。
And it is on this album Soul Christmas.
它收录在《灵魂圣诞》这张专辑里。
There's this compilation Soul Christmas that I decorate the Christmas tree.
有一张叫《灵魂圣诞》的合辑，我每次装饰圣诞树都会听。
Our family plays that album every year when I decorate the Christmas tree, which has all soul versions of Christmas songs.
我们家每年我装饰圣诞树时都会放这张专辑，里面全是圣诞歌的灵歌版本。
That one's a banger of that song.
那首歌真的是首神曲。
I was we were Carter and I were because Carter and I, you know, met and started working together essentially in life in college Playing in a soul band together.
当时我和卡特……因为我和卡特，你知道的，我们俩在大学里相遇并开始一起生活和工作，一起在一个灵乐队里弹奏。
We played covers of soul songs.
我们翻唱过很多灵歌。
We never played this one.
但我们从来没弹过这首。
I wish we'd like done it.
我真希望我们当时能翻唱一下。
It's a great song And it really worked.
这是一首好歌，而且真的很带感。
It's just a great soul song.
它就是一首极棒的灵歌。
Yeah, it really worked.
对，真的很有味道。
Yeah, I also think this is the second time Well, Ted doesn't say it first, but blow her mind whole mind whole became that was a that was a Phil and Chris thing, right?
对，我也觉得这是第二次……好吧，泰德不是第一个说的，但“震惊我全家”这个梗后来成了菲尔和克里斯的常用语，对吧？
That's in Chris.
那是克里斯的梗。
That's what definitely like Lord Miller speak from Chris and Phil Well, planted in season one, brought it back in season two.
这绝对是克里斯和菲尔——也就是罗德·米勒的说话风格。第一季埋下伏笔，第二季又把它拿出来用。
Yeah.
对。
Also another question for you is the college flashback of Lily and Ted having a sandwich, which I don't think we'd established sandwich as the euphemism yet, had we, for possible?
还有一个问题想问你，就是莉莉和泰德在大学里吃“三明治”的那段回忆杀——我觉得当时我们还没把“三明治”当作大麻的委婉说法吧？
I don't think so.
我觉得还没有。
我觉得没有。
But is this the debut of college Ted's wig?
不过这难道是大学时期泰德假发造型的首秀吗？
No.
不是。
I think, oh shit, we, we, we, we saw Marshall and Lily meeting in college.
我想……哦天哪，我们……我们看过马歇尔和莉莉在大学相遇。
Did we ever see Ted in college?
我们以前见过大学时代的泰德吗？
This might be the debut of the wig.
这可能真的是那顶假发的首秀。
I love the purpose that flashback serves.
我非常喜欢那段闪回所起到的作用。
That is the sweetest part of this episode.
那是这集里最温馨的部分。
The Ted knows Lily that well.
泰德居然对莉莉了解得那么深。
They go back that far.
他们认识的时间那么久了。
It so makes the sale that they are also best friends.
这极大地证明了他们也是最好的朋友。
And that he remembers this stone night in college where she revealed this thing.
而且他还记得大学里那个喝醉的夜晚，当时莉莉吐露了那个心愿。
They were so high, but he remembered it.
他们当时嗨大了，但他却一直记着。
Marshall couldn't find the outside.
马歇尔甚至找不到门朝哪边。
I couldn't find the outside.
我连门朝哪边都找不到。
To get to the concert.
去不了演唱会现场。
He's been gone for long enough that they think he's already gone to a whole concert.
他消失了足够长的时间，以至于大家都以为他已经去看完一整场演唱会了。
But he's just wandering around the dorm and that's how high they are.
结果他只是在宿舍里瞎转悠，可见他们当时嗨得有多厉害。
And yet Ted remembers this crucial like childhood wish of Lily that he helps fulfill for her.
即便如此，泰德依然记得莉莉这个至关重要的童年愿望，并帮她实现了。
And that's the fact that that unlocks it and brings them back together is a delight.
正是这个细节解开了心结，让他们重新走到一起，这真是太美妙了。
I thought that was a really, for our first Christmas episode, that was a good like heartwarming Christmas payoff.
我觉得对于我们的第一集圣诞特辑来说，这是一个非常温馨且圆满的圣诞结局。
I love, we'll give it, we'll give the donate the presents to charity and the girl gets excited.
我喜欢把礼物捐给慈善机构的那一段，那个小女孩兴奋极了。
Not you charity.
不是指你，慈善机构。
Moon Zappa failing that one.
月亮·扎帕没能演好那个角色。
Yeah.
对。
So, okay, so this really made me laugh.
所以，好吧，这段真的把我逗笑了。
When they ask him, you know, Ted, what's your favorite Bible verse?
当他们问他——你知道的，泰德，你最喜欢的圣经经文是什么？
And he starts hedging on it.
然后他开始支支吾吾地打太极。
It's almost verbatim of when Trump is asked, what is your favorite Bible verse?
这简直跟特朗普被问到“你最喜欢的圣经经文是什么”时的反应一模一样。
So many good ones.
有太多精彩的经文了。
I couldn't even pick.
我甚至选不出来。
I couldn't pick a favorite.
我挑不出最喜欢哪一个。
Like Ted does that exact speech.
泰德说的那番话简直一模一样。
That's so funny, it is the doggade my homework response, it really is, but I love the Pulp Fiction reference yet another Pulp Fiction reference, what he says, well that one in Pulp Fiction is pretty cool, the one in Pulp Fiction is pretty cool, that was great, I mean we have many different Tarantino references and many in Pulp Fiction and that is another one that and it'd forgotten completely about that one.
太搞笑了，这完全就是“小狗吃了我的作业”式的回答，真的是这样。但我很喜欢里面对《低俗小说》的致敬，又是一个《低俗小说》的梗，当他说——好吧，《低俗小说》里的那个真的很酷，《低俗小说》里的那个真的很酷——太棒了，我是说我们用了许多不同的昆汀电影梗，其中有很多来自《低俗小说》，这又是另一个我完全忘得精光的梗。
And it's right before Samuel Jackson opened fire.
而且就在塞缪尔·杰克逊开枪之前。
Quinton, please come on the podcast.
昆汀，请来我们的播客吧。
I'm gonna say that.
我要把这话说出来。
Yeah, Quinton.
对，昆汀。
That was Quinton Tarantino.
刚才那是昆汀·塔伦蒂诺。
Sending out the...
发出呼叫……
We're trying desperately to reach you.
我们一直在拼命联系你。
I've tried to agencies.
我联系过各大经纪公司。
I've DM'd your podcast.
我也给你的播客发过私信。
I'm trying to make things.
我一直在努力尝试。
We know you love this show.
我们知道你很喜欢这部剧。
We love you.
我们也很喜欢你。
We'd love to talk to you.
我们很想跟你聊聊。
Anyone out there who knows.
如果外面的任何人知道的话。
If anybody can put us in touch with Quinton Tarantino, that'd be cool.
如果有人能帮我们联系上昆汀·塔伦蒂诺，那就太酷了。
Yeah.
对。
I love, I told you by the way that I was at a party with Quinton Tarantino and he came up to me and just keep down around.
顺便说一句，我之前说过，我曾和昆汀·塔伦蒂诺参加过同一个派对，他朝我走过来，然后……
You've gotten the closest of anyone, Josh.
乔希，你是所有人里离他最近的一个了。
It's true.
确实如此。
All eyes are turning to you.
所有人的目光都转向你了。
Got out.
拿到了。
He gave me his number, but it's a phone number that I don't think works anymore.
他给了我他的电话号码，但我觉得那个号码现在已经打不通了。
Wait, I haven't tried it, should I call him?
等等，我还没试过呢，我要不要给他打个电话？
Let's call him right now.
我们现在就给他打个电话吧。
现在就打。
Now, now.
就是现在。
Call him up, leave a message.
打给他，给他留个言。
Call him, that'll work.
打给他，这招肯定管用。
I'll call it afterwards.
我录完节目再打。
We, yeah, we left.
我们，对，我们走吧。
Ted's nephew was very cute.
泰德的那个小侄子非常可爱。
I remember thinking that kid was very cute.
我记得当时觉得那孩子可爱极了。
Yeah, very cute.
对，非常可爱。
He's probably 35 years old.
他现在大概35岁了吧。
Yeah, you know.
对啊，你知道的。
Well, hold on.
等等。
Are we talking about Ted's young cousin, Grant, I guess, is the, the, the name?
我们说的是泰德的小表弟格兰特吗？如果我没记错名字的话？
Was it right, Reynolds?
是叫雷诺兹吗？
Played by Zachary Adam Gordon, because, yeah, why?
由扎卡里·亚当·戈登饰演，因为，对，为什么？
The internet points out and I believe it's confirmed.
网友们指出，而且我相信已经被证实了。
He also played Barney's fake son in the yips.
他还饰演过巴尼在《眼皮跳》里那个假儿子。
Oh, so he was like, just part of the, how I met your mother family players.
哦，所以他就像是……“老爸老妈浪漫史”御用演员家族的一员。
Like we just gave him, it was like the acting troupe.
就像我们给了他一个角色，这就好比是一个演员剧团。
You're like, this week, you're going to be Barney's son.
你会觉得：“这周由你来演巴尼的儿子。”
That's also very Tarantino, it's like, here's our actors.
这也很有昆汀的风格，就像是：这就是我们的演员班底。
Yeah, there's only so many of them if we're gonna reuse a lot of them.
对，如果我们想大量重复使用演员的话，人选也就那么几个。
Yeah, it's just Tim Roth.
对，就像蒂姆·罗斯那样。
Tim Roth, week to week.
蒂姆·罗斯，一周又一周。
He's the Tim Roth of our verse, of him in verse, that kid.
他是我们宇宙里的蒂姆·罗斯，诗意般的他，那小子。
Hilarious, I forgot that.
太搞笑了，我都忘了。
Yeah.
对啊。
Do you think on the tag with Jason and the cookie dough, here's my feeling.
你觉得关于杰森和曲奇面团那个尾声，我的感觉是这样的。
I think he disliked having to be the guy who eats the cookie dough, but probably enjoyed the cookie dough.
我觉得他可能讨厌当那个必须吃曲奇面团的人，但大概挺喜欢曲奇面团本身的。
I said, yeah, we watched the tag.
我说，对啊，我们看了那个尾声。
I said, I said to Rebecca, I was like, This is Jason Seagull's greatest nightmare that we made him.
我说，我对丽贝卡说，这简直是杰森·席格尔的终极噩梦，是我们逼他拍的。
It's a bad, there's so many great sides to Marshall and Jason embraced them and played so many of them beautifully.
马歇尔这个角色有太多精彩的层面了，杰森把它们都融入了进去，并把其中很多面都演得极其精彩。
Whenever he had to be the guy who wanted to eat the cookie dough, it was not his favorite thing.
但每当他得扮演那个想吃曲奇面团的人时，那可不是他最喜欢的事。
But I'll tell you this, he's still, he almost, the stuff you knew he didn't like, he leaned into it, his way of coping, was it, was he leaned into it more?
不过我要说的是，他依然，他几乎——那些你知道他不喜欢的东西，他反而会倾心投入，他应对的方式，是不是，是不是他投入得更多了？
It did, which is kind of a virtue as an actor.
确实如此，作为演员这算是一种美德吧。
Like, he was like, I was hired to do this and I'm gonna do it almost like too much.
就像是，他会觉得，我被雇来就是干这个的，那我甚至要把它演得有点过头。
Like I'm just gonna lean into it a little hard, too hard.
就像我就是要狠狠地投入进去，甚至用力过猛。
Yeah, I'm gonna give you more than you want because you're making me do this, but I'm gonna do it a little bit.
对，我要给你超出你想要的量，因为你逼我这么干，但我就是要稍微过火一点。
And he's so funny with whatever it is.
而且不管是什么内容，他总是能演得那么搞笑。
God bless you, Jason Segal.
上帝保佑你，杰森·席格尔。
You guys offset it by letting him say, you would say, here's seven legal phrases, set them to music.
你们通过让他说台词来平衡这一点，你会说，这里有七个法律术语，把它们谱成曲。
Yeah, exactly.
对，没错。
And he would just come up with amazing stuff.
而他总能想出绝妙的点子。
He would love it.
他会乐在其中。
他会非常喜欢。
And he got to be the Christmas hero.
而且他还成了圣诞英雄。
He's basically Santa in this episode.
他在这一集里基本上就是圣诞老人。
He had hero moments, he was great.
他有很多英雄高光时刻，他演得太棒了。
And then we made him eat cookie dough at the end, which I like the montage of him helping out the UPS guy.
然后最后我们让他吃曲奇面团，不过我挺喜欢他帮快递员的那段蒙太奇的。
Yeah, it was really sweet.
对，真的很温馨。
You know how we started this episode by talking about all the people that how I met your mother taught English to?
你知道我们这一集开头是怎么聊到《老爸老妈的浪漫史》教过多少人英语的吗？
Yeah.
对啊。
I mean, Jason Siegel gave generations of law students be in a lawyer head, bear to be awesome while they're studying.
我是说，杰森·席格尔让好几代法学院学生在脑海里自带律师光环，在学习时也能酷劲十足。
And lawyers, and lawyers to catch phrase.
还有律师，以及律师们的口头禅。
Yeah.
对。
对啊。
He got to be, he had a lot of good stuff to do.
他有很多发挥空间，演得很棒。
And like, everyone's when I was like, all right, I guess I'm the cookie.
大家有时候会觉得，好吧，我猜我就是那个吃曲奇的。
But you know, all right, let's do this now.
但你知道，好吧，我们现在就把它拍了吧。
There were all, I mean, quiz any of the five of us or anyone on any show.
所有这些——我是说，随便问我们五个人或者任何剧组里的谁。
And it's like, there's certain notes you just are delighted to hit that you're like this, and certain ones that are new and fresh and other ones, you're like, okay, this is them going to that well where I have to do the thing.
就会发现，有些梗你就是演得很开心，会觉得太棒了，而有些梗是崭新新鲜的，还有些梗你会觉得，好吧，这是他们又在老调重弹，逼我做那个动作了。
And which is fair.
这也是情理之中。
Yeah.
对。
That you're like, I'm getting paid a pretty good amount of money to do this, I'm not gonna complain.
你会觉得，我拍这个拿了相当不错的片酬，我没什么好抱怨的。
You know, I'm just going to do it.
你知道的，我照做就是了。
It's there's no way to enjoy everything you're asked to do across 200 episodes, but the hero move is to do it anyway.
在拍了200集的跨度里，不可能要求你做的每一件事你都喜欢，但英雄的做法就是无论如何都把它完成。
There's probably there was probably a better tag here than that, but the sheer Christmas tradition joy of like looking forward to that stupid thing every year, I think a lot of people can relate to that.
这里可能本来可以有比这更好的尾声，但那种每年期待着那个蠢东西的纯粹的圣诞传统快乐，我想很多人都能感同身受。
That actually feels very real to me.
那对我来说其实感觉非常真实。
There's definitely shit like that in my life.
我的生活里绝对也有这种烂事。
I thought his there is a little runner of people who I mean, there's that Super Bowl episode where everyone tries to not know the score.
我觉得他——这里有个小小的支线，关于那些人——我是说，有一集超级碗的插曲，每个人都在极力避免知道比分。
I mean, he's trying, he doesn't want to have it spoiled.
我是说，他在努力，他不想被剧透。
He's trying to get out of here.
他在设法离开这儿。
It was very like that.
这非常像那种感觉。
It was funny to watch him try to get out of the apartment without looking.
看他如何努力不去看周围并离开公寓，真的很好笑。
Is that a reindeer?
那是一只驯鹿吗？
I don't even want to know, don't tell me.
我甚至不想知道，别告诉我。
Yeah, it's a fun one.
对，这集挺好玩的。
It's a great, it's our first Christmas episode.
这是一部很棒的作品，这是我们的第一集圣诞特辑。
It ends with everybody, the gang coming out to get Ted and Lily having that flashback.
故事以大家伙儿——死党们出来找泰德，而莉莉闪回过往而告终。
And their reconciliation at the end is really moving.
最后他们的破镜重圆真的很感人。
It's really sweet.
真的很温馨。
I'm really proud of this is our first Christmas episode.
我真的为这是我们的第一集圣诞特辑感到骄傲。
We'd hit all those and checked all those other holiday boxes, but we hadn't done a Christmas one and it had to happen.
我们已经打卡并勾选了所有其他假期的方框，但我们还没拍过圣诞特辑，而这是必须要有的。
And I think I think it's a good one.
而且我觉得，我觉得这是一集很棒的剧集。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
还有这位老人家，他激励了我，爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials.
现在是广告时间。
End of commercials?
广告结束？
Back to show.
回到节目。
Greg.
格雷格。
Yes, Alec.
什么事，亚历克。
We got a post from Haley from the Facebook group who says simply, this is so sad.
我们收到了来自Facebook群组里海莉的一条动态，她简单地写道，这也太让人难过了。
And she's of course referring to the fact that how I met your mother is no longer going to be on Netflix.
她当然是指《老爸老妈的浪漫史》将不再在Netflix上播放这件事。
Can you help out Hailey and the Legion of fans who are asking what is going on here?
你能帮帮海莉以及广大询问这究竟是怎么回事的粉丝军团吗？
Yes, Hailey is not alone.
可以，海莉并不孤单。
We're hearing a lot from people who are not thrilled that Hemium is back off of Netflix.
我们听到很多对于《老妈》下架Netflix感到很不爽的人的反馈。
Yeah, we just wanted to talk about it to acknowledge the bajillion questions we're getting about it.
对，我们之所以想聊聊这个，是为了回应我们收到的关于此事的成千上万个问题。
Yeah, we were on, we've been on and off of Netflix over the years, how much a mother, it was very helpful.
是的，我们多年来在Netflix上上下下好几次，《老妈》这剧以前在上面帮了大忙。
When we were on the air, in the middle of the run, we got on Netflix for the first time, it really helped the show.
当我们在电视上热播时，在剧集播出的中途，我们第一次登陆了Netflix，这确实对剧集帮助很大。
We will remain the Hemiumers, eternally grateful to Netflix for that.
我们这群“老妈迷”将永远为此对Netflix心存感激。
But it is a business, we were off for a while, and then recently we're back on for a couple of years.
但这毕竟是门生意，我们下架了一段时间，然后最近又重新上线了几年。
And the business is changing so fast, there's so much going on with all of these streamers and all these companies and all the corporations that own the streamers.
而现在的商业模式变化太快了，所有这些流媒体平台、所有这些公司以及拥有流媒体的各大企业之间发生了太多的事情。
basically the term deal was up and Netflix and the owner of How Much A Mother Disney parted ways.
基本上就是版权协议到期了，Netflix和《老妈》的版权所有者迪士尼分道扬镳了。
They didn't renew the deal.
他们没有续签协议。
Disney owns Hulu and How Much A Mother continues to be on Hulu.
迪士尼拥有Hulu，而《老妈》将继续在Hulu上播出。
There's a lot of that.
这种事情现在有很多。
There's a lot of the company that owns it puts it on there.
拥有它的公司把它放在自家的平台上播出的情况有很多。
It's not as much around multiple other streamers besides the owner of the show.
除了剧集所有者之外，它不再像以前那样在多个其他流媒体平台上随处可见了。
It's been great to me on more than one, which we have been on and off for years and years.
能在多个平台上播出真的很棒，我们在上面上上下下好多年了。
We'll see if it happens again.
我们会看看这种事还会不会再次发生。
But right now, we just wanted to be clear, it's not on Netflix, we're sorry, it's not our decision.
但目前，我们只想明确一点：它已经不在Netflix上了，对此我们很遗憾，但这并非我们的决定。
But it is still on Hulu internationally.
不过在国际上它仍然在Hulu上。
It's on Disney Plus, as I said, Disney owns all of that anyway.
正如我所说，它也在Disney Plus上，反正迪士尼拥有这一切。
You can also buy the entire series, I believe on Amazon, on Google Play, on Apple, you can just buy the series and own the whole series if you want.
我想你也可以在亚马逊、谷歌商店、苹果上购买整部剧集，如果你想的话，你可以直接买下并拥有整部剧。
But if you want to stream it in America, it's Hulu now.
但如果你想在美国境内进行流媒体点播，现在是在Hulu上。
And we will certainly update if there's anything else that comes about on that or anything changes.
如果有任何关于这方面的新进展或任何改变，我们肯定会及时更新的。
But for the time being, we will acknowledge and own that yes, it's off of Netflix.
但目前，我们承认并坦白，是的，它确实从Netflix下架了。
We're bummed out.
我们也很郁闷。
It's been great to be on there, but Hulu is also an awesome partner and an awesome home for how much your mother please go find us there.
能在上面播出曾经很棒，但Hulu也是一个极佳的合作伙伴和《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的绝佳归宿，请大家去那里找我们吧。
All right, welcome back.
好的，欢迎回来。
We are at that perilous moment where we introduce a section called General Questions.
我们来到了那个充满危险的时刻，我们要介绍一个名为“常规问题”的环节。
General Questions.
常规问题。
We had the yips on that though.
不过我们在那上面表现得有点怯场。
We were all afraid to do it too soon.
我们当时也都害怕做得太早。
That's why it's perilous.
这就是它的危险所在。
That's why it's perilous, you were lying.
这就是它的危险所在，你在撒谎。
That's why, yeah.
这就是，是的。
I blame Alex most of the time, but we're going to take some questions from you, our listeners, fans of the show, if you would like to write in a question, if you would like to give us an audio or written testimony of your love of the show, when you started watching it, why it means something to you, so much to you, any other wonderful facts or disclosures You'd like to share the- Anybody else learn English?
我大多数时候都怪亚历克斯，但我们要回答你们的问题，我们的听众、节目的粉丝，如果你想写信提问，如果你想给我们一段音频或文字表白，表达你对这个节目有多么热爱，你是什么时候开始看它的，为什么它对你意义非凡，有什么其他美妙的事实或爆料你想分享的——还有人学英语吗？
If anyone else learn English- Anyone else learn English language?
如果还有其他人学英语——还有人学英语吗？
Just let us know.
告诉我们一声就行。
It's one of our favorite parts of doing this podcast is to hear from people about how the show is affected them and how the show has changed for them as the years have gone by.
制作这个播客最让我们喜欢的部分之一，就是听到大家讲述这部剧是如何影响他们的，以及随着岁月的流逝，这部剧对他们来说发生了怎样的变化。
Just go to how we made your mother.com, H-Y-M-W-M.com.
只需访问 how we made your mother.com，即 H-Y-M-W-M.com。
Either one, go to contact and just follow the instructions.
随便哪个，点击联系，然后按照说明操作就行。
It should be pretty clear.
应该挺清楚的。
Alec, what do you have for us today?
亚历克，你今天给我们准备了什么？
I think you said H-Y-M-W-I get it wrong every time.
我想你刚刚说的是 H-Y-M-W-I，我每次都拼错。
H.
H。
W.
W。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
W.
W。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
W.
W。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
W.
W。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
H.
H。
W.
W。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
M.
M。
Y.
Y。
It's hard.
这很难。
Yeah.
对。
It's hard because you bring it to him and then you get the it's another yips.
这很难，因为你把它拿给他，然后你就又得到了那种心理障碍。
We have a lot of yips.
我们有很多这种心理障碍。
All right.
好吧。
So we have questions of all types of course, that gets the core of what the show is but we also have a lot of literal behind the scenes.
所以我们当然有各种类型的问题，这触及了节目的核心，但我们也了解了很多幕后的真实情况。
Jessica, our friend, Jessica Wallace, X O X asks is the hallway into the apartment a set that was taken apart after each time it was or was it always attached to the main apartment set, Josh?
我们的朋友杰西卡·华莱士（Jessica Wallace，XOX）问，通往公寓的走廊是一个每次拍完就会拆掉的布景，还是它一直连着主要的公寓布景，乔希？
That's such a good question, but Craig, help me remember.
这是一个非常好的问题，但是克雷格，帮我回忆一下。
I think it was kind of floating in and out.
我觉得它好像是那种可以临时移进移出的。
I think it floated in and out, yeah.
我觉得它是移进移出的，对。
That bigger hallway that we're tracking them down a hallway, that's built out more than what's usually there.
那个较大的走廊，就是我们跟着他们走的那条走廊，比平时那里的结构要搭得更长一些。
There has to be a little something there because you see out it when the door opens and closes, but I think it was designed in a way where the little bit that you see when the door opens is just there.
那里必须得有一点结构，因为当门开闭时你能从里面看到外面，但我觉得它的设计是这样的：门打开时你看到的那一小部分就固定在那里。
And then when you're actually gonna shoot a scene in a hallway, we had to add that.
然后当你要真正在走廊里拍一场戏时，我们就得把那部分加上。
That was like a swing set.
那就像一个活动布景。
I always liked hallways scenes for some reason.
不知为什么，我一直很喜欢走廊的戏。
I always found them to be fun and intimate and weird.
我总是觉得它们很有趣、很亲密又很古怪。
I did want to give Neil another shout out, his kind of descent into sickness and madness in the hallway where he has something in the ground is really funny, yeah.
我确实想再次表扬一下尼尔，他在走廊里那种陷入疾病和疯狂的状态，地上还放着东西，真的很搞笑，对。
Him coughing his way out of frame, falling to the ground.
他一路咳嗽着出画，然后摔倒在地上。
He really looked like you got physically hurt doing that.
他拍那个的时候看起来真的很像身体受了伤。
And the thud is a real thud.
而且那个闷响是真实的闷响。
He would thrust his body in ways that were like, I mean, I just, I really to this day, I still think one of the funniest bits of physical comedy I've ever seen is after the marathon on the subway.
他会用各种方式猛烈地摔砸自己的身体，我的意思是，直到今天我依然觉得，我见过最好笑的身体喜剧片段之一，就是马拉松之后在地铁里的那场戏。
Oh my God, him on the subway.
哦，天哪，他在地铁里。
Of him trying to stand up and realizing that's not his legs.
他试图站起来，却意识到那根本不是他的腿。
Unbelievable, unbelievable.
难以置信，难以置信。
He falls out of frame face first in a way I don't know how he didn't die.
他面朝下摔出画外，我都不知道他当时怎么没死。
He was so committed, that was it right away.
他太投入了，从一开始就是这样。
He came in an audition for the role of Barney with that laser tag scene and did like a crazy shoulder roll flip, slammed into our wall and our offices, the pictures shook on the wall, like the framed pictures on the wall shook.
他来为巴尼这个角色试镜时，就带着那个激光枪战的场景，做了一个疯狂的侧滚翻，重重地撞在我们办公室的墙上，墙上的画都震动了，就像墙上挂着相框的画都震动了一样。
I can remember it to this day.
我至今都记得。
was like, I'm getting this job.
当时就觉得，我非得录用这个人不可。
Yeah.
对。
And he just never stopped.
而且他从未停止过。
He never stopped that level of commitment.
他从未停止过那种程度的投入。
Hey, it's cow me asks as time goes on, but especially in this episode, we see Ted is clearly a massive jazz fan.
嘿，“cow me”问，随着时间的推移，尤其是这一集里，我们看到泰德显然是个铁杆爵士乐迷。
He has a lot of posters in his room thanks to the wide shots of Barney's sick and dead.
多亏了巴尼那间又酷又死的房间的广角镜头，我们可以看到他的房间里有很多海报。
He starts wearing more and more jazz graphic t-shirts.
他开始穿越来越多的爵士乐印花T恤。
And in season for his best burger in New York, Regis Philbin even calls him Satchelmouth, who inspired that part of Ted's personality and why did it remain just a subtlety?
而在第四季的“纽约最好吃的汉堡”那一集里，雷吉·菲尔宾甚至叫他“大嘴”（Satchelmouth），是谁启发了泰德个性的这一部分，为什么它一直只是一种微妙的细节？
I'm still stuck on Satchelmouth.
我还是卡在“大嘴”（Satchelmouth）这个词上了。
I'm still stuck on the meaning of that.
我还在琢磨这个词的意思。
Is he going for great Satchmo?
他是在说伟大的萨奇莫（Satchmo）吗？
Is he going for like Lumi Armstrong?
他是在说像路易·阿姆斯特朗那样的人吗？
Is that what Satchmo is?
萨奇莫是这个意思吗？
Oh, yeah, that's what he's thinking.
哦，对，他想的就是这个。
I think there's some confusion happening.
我觉得这里面产生了一些混淆。
Yeah.
对。
I think there's a glitch.
我觉得出了一点小故障。
But I thought he was talking about the Utah Jazz at first, and I was like, that's not, That wasn't his team.
但一开始我还以为他在说犹他爵士队，当时我想，那不对，那不是他的球队。
Yeah, you know, I think in a weird, well, was it, was that a carderism, like a kind of like whiskey, cigar, jazz, kind of affectation?
对，你知道的，我觉得在某种奇怪的情况下，这算是一种卡特式的风格吗？有点像威士忌、雪茄、爵士乐那种做作的风格？
Has kind of overall sort of a feet side of town.
带有一种老派小镇的感觉。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对，对，对，对。
He likes classical music too, classical literature too.
他也喜欢古典音乐，古典文学也喜欢。
But I can't say that any one of us was a huge jazz guy, that that's why we put it in.
但我不能说我们当中有谁是个超级爵士乐迷，所以才把这个放进去。
I feel it's more in the decor than.
我觉得这更多体现在布景装饰里。
It might have been one of those reverse engineered things because I think they started putting me in like jazz t-shirts, like, do you know what I'm saying?
这可能是那种事后反向推导出来的东西，因为我觉得他们开始给我穿那种爵士乐T恤，呃，你知道我的意思吗？
Like, I think they were, I think then you were like, I don't think we were writing it that way as much as like wardrobe and set deck or like this, Ted would like this.
就像，我觉得他们当时在做，而你会觉得，我们写剧本的时候可能没写那么多，反而是服装和布景部门觉得，泰德会喜欢这个。
I think that might have been like a little bit and maybe then we decided to reference it a little bit.
我觉得这可能有点那种意思，然后也许我们决定在台词里稍微呼应一下。
It's a very interesting like ecosystem where in all parts of the ecosystem kind of feed each other in some kind of cycle, like the, you know, wardrobe and set deck will do something and we'll go like, oh yeah, maybe we'll Maybe we'll talk about that.
这是一个非常有趣的生态系统，生态系统的各个部分在某种循环中相互滋养，比如，你知道的，服装和布景部门会做一些事，然后我们会说，哦，对，也许我们可以谈谈这个。
It's not always for the writer.
这并不总是为了编剧而设的。
Well, they're reading the script, like they're reading it through the lens of like what clothes were these people were wearing, what's on the walls, but they're also paying attention to the characters because all that stuff is character revealing.
嗯，他们在读剧本时，会从这些人在穿什么衣服、墙上有什么东西的角度去解读，但他们也会关注角色，因为所有这些东西都能揭示角色的性格。
Yeah, exactly.
对，确实如此。
And that's, yeah, I would give them the credit there.
而且，是的，我觉得这一点上他们值得表扬。
I think that's much more from like the art design perspective of Ted than from the writing side.
我觉得这更多是出于泰德的美术设计视角，而不是编剧层面。
If you have questions, just check us on Instagram.
如果你有任何问题，可以在Instagram上关注我们。
It's a great way to send in your questions as well as through the website, as Josh had mentioned.
正如乔希所提到的，这也是发送你的问题以及通过网站联系我们的好方法。
And another great thing to send in through the website are these letters that we read and we have a lovely one today, Josh?
通过网站发来的另一个好东西就是我们读的这些信件，我们今天有一封很棒的信，乔希？
Yeah.
对。
So this one is from Sarah.
所以这封信来自莎拉。
Hi, guys.
大家好。
I'm one of those millennials now in my 30s who saw this on TV when I was really young.
我是那种三十多岁的千禧一代，我很小的时候就在电视上看过这部剧。
Then during uni, watched it as it blew up with my friends.
后来在大学期间，看着它和朋友们一起火了起来。
My partner at the time spoke so highly of this show because in his words, it was realistic as in so great to see a show where people hung out at bars and not coffee places, lived in tiny flats and struggled with life rather than pretending to struggle.
我当时的伴侣对这部剧评价很高，因为用他的话说，它很现实，能看到一部剧里的人是在酒吧而不是咖啡馆闲逛，住在狭小的公寓里，为生活挣扎而不是假装挣扎，这太棒了。
Years on, I remain perpetually single and I watch him yum every year.
多年以后，我依然单身，每年都会重温这部剧。
Not intentionally, it's just comfort food for me.
倒不是故意为之，它只是我的精神慰藉。
For some reason, I always start with the Christmas episode where Lily is a Grinch.
不知为何，我总是从莉莉当格林奇的那集圣诞节开始看。
Every time I watch for fun, every time I get drawn in and every time I ball my eyes out nearly every episode of the last season, because the romantic in me, who at this point is very cynical about life, still has a glimmer of hope that whoever it is I'm supposed to meet is just around the corner.
每次我为了好玩而看，每次都会被吸引进去，而且最后一季几乎每一集我都会哭得稀里哗啦，因为我内心深处那个浪漫主义者——尽管此时对生活已经非常愤世嫉俗——依然怀有一丝希望，觉得我命中注定要遇到的人就在拐角处。
I am very much a Ted.
我真的很像泰德。
Like a lot of people are saying, HSP, highly sensitive person, hard on sleep.
就像很多人说的那样，HSP（高敏感人群），睡眠质量差。
And at this point in my life, I super relate to the single fatigue Ted has towards the end of the show.
在我人生的这个阶段，我极其感同身受泰德在剧集快结束时那种单身的疲惫感。
That'd be a good episode title, single fatigue.
这会是一个很好的剧集标题，单身疲惫。
But enough of that misery, genuinely, I always end up bawling not out of sadness, but hope.
不过那些悲伤就说到这里，说实话，我最后总是泪流满面，不是因为难过，而是因为希望。
And also just gratefulness that I am who I am and that I can feel this way and therefore experience life to its very fullest.
还有感激，感激我是现在的我，感激我有这种感受，从而能够体验最完整的人生。
I really get a lot of lessons out of the show every time I watch, and I'm really grateful for the reminder that there's always an older me who will see things differently in retrospect.
每次看这部剧，我真的都能学到很多东西，并且我很感激它提醒了我：回首过去时，总有一个更成熟的我会有不同的看法。
When I'm feeling particularly blue about my bad luck and love, I often think about how there's some plonker out there who hasn't met anyone like me yet, and I've not met anyone like them yet, and that makes me go giddy in the moment.
当我因为在爱情中运气不佳而感到格外沮丧时，我经常会想，外面一定有个笨蛋还没遇到过像我这样的人，而我也还没遇到过像他们那样的人，这让我当下感到一阵眩晕般的兴奋。
How are we spelling plonker?
“笨蛋”（plonker）这个词怎么拼？
Can you use, can you?
你能用一下吗，你可以吗？
Oh, and K-E-R.
哦，还有 K-E-R。
I love this word so much, plonker.
我太喜欢这个词了，笨蛋（plonker）。
And that's her dream.
这就是她的梦想。
I want to be the plonker.
我想当那个笨蛋。
Yeah.
对。
Some plonker out there who hasn't met anyone like me yet.
外面的某个笨蛋还没遇到过像我这样的人。
And I've never met anyone like them yet.
而我也还没遇到过像他们那样的人。
And that makes me go giddy in the moment.
这让我此刻感到眩晕。
Thank you entirely for this.
非常感谢你们带来这一切。
With love, Sarah.
爱你的，莎拉。
Sarah, Sarah, may you meet your plonker?
莎拉，莎拉，愿你能遇到你的那个笨蛋！
How I met my plonker.
老爸老妈的浪漫史（How I met my plonker）。
When in just the right time.
在恰当的时候。
I also, I also we've talked about this, but I hear when I hear from women who relate to Ted so much, I always find it comes up a lot, right?
我也，我们讨论过这个，但当我听到那些对泰德非常有共鸣的女性的心声时，我总是发现这种情况经常出现，对吧？
I was thinking the exact same thing.
我刚才也在想完全一样的事情。
We hear that a lot.
我们经常听到这种反馈。
I think that's great.
我觉得这太棒了。
Yeah.
对。
Well, Sarah, thanks for that lovely letter.
好吧，莎拉，谢谢你写来这封可爱的信。
We're wishing you all the best and we're glad we can accompany you through this strange journey called life.
我们祝你一切都好，也高兴能陪伴你走过这段被称为人生的奇妙旅程。
I love that I love that the show has made it around the world in the way it has and we're hearing we started this episode with learning English and we ended the episode in England, I think.
我很高兴这部剧能以这种方式火遍全球，我觉得我们这集节目开始于学习英语，而结束于英国。
It's really- And we learned something cool.
这真的是——而且我们学到了一些酷炫的知识。
And we learned something cool.
而且我们学到了一些酷炫的知识。
We've been some real, some Plankarisms.
我们了解了一些真正的英国俚语。
Well, to all you Plankars out there, thank you for joining us.
好吧，所有的笨蛋们，谢谢你们加入我们。
We loved being with you and we'll see you next time.
我们很享受和你们在一起的时光，我们下次再见。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔希·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
由 Office Ladies Network 和 Audacy 联合呈现与发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
节目由我，亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马塔塔（Doug Matata）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves）。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是 Z 世代大师，是艾米丽·布隆伯格（Emily Blumberg）。
artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔希·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在 Substack 上订阅乔希·拉德纳的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐以及其他内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《That's Not How It Happened》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Fathers Society）。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息——本节目旨在为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的持续活动——请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，它会跳舞。